this year for christmas i really just
wanted to spread good cheer and
highlight the efforts of someone in the
community who's doing real good
and the person that we're visiting today
is stan simulu gave back in a big way
this holiday season
giving a single dad who recently lost
his wife to cancer a chance for a
christmas that would be
extra merry i think about how hard it
must be to be going through that but
also
of all times and of all places to be
going through it in the middle of covid
and the lockdown and whatnot
and i also know that he honors his late
wife's memory through the joanna juan
chang foundation which
encourages girls to embrace careers in
stem
and in entrepreneurship so today we're
going to pay them a visit and we're
going to
just say hi and spread some good share
and really just shed a light
on the foundation what it does uh what
its mandate is and
also just to just to say thank you for
everything that he does
the shang chi star teamed up with the
canadian chinese youth athletic
association
to give the family with something they
can enjoy together while in lockdown
we brought you a little something that's
brought me a lot of joy
in the last few weeks in particular
since it's come out
but i'm hoping it'll bring you guys joy
too
just give it a big rip
[Music]
but the playstation was just the cherry
on top simu also made sure to pay it
forward
donating to the family's foundation um
we wanted to donate a thousand dollars
to your foundation
now you're so welcome you're such an
inspiration to everyone